only have say 90 minutes in a workday
what actually is going to make a
difference what is going to move the
needle in my career and my business and
often it's it's a very different answer
than you'd expect it's this moment of
truth where you have to you have to look
yourself in the mirror and just be so
honest as long as i thought that money
was evil business was bad everything in
that world was bad those are some of the
most powerful forces in the world i was
like uh
you know someone in the desert finding
water i saw and i studied i really
looked into the numbers like what
actually makes a difference in people's
lives and honestly you can boil it down
to one thing
hey friends and welcome back to deep
dive the ongoing podcast where every
week i sit down with inspiring authors
creators entrepreneurs and other
inspiring people uh inspiring i said
that twice doesn't matter and we talk
about strategies and tools that can help
us live our best lives and we talk about
their journeys and how they got to where
they are this conversation that you're
about to hear is a conversation between
me and my internet friend and now real
life friend thiago forte tiago is one of
the world's foremost experts on
productivity apparently and has written
a book which i've got here somewhere
called building a second brain it's a
book that's just come out fairly
recently but actually i took his course
building second brain in 2019 and it
completely changed my life i would say
it changed the way i approached my
business with the way i approached my
life and content creation and my youtube
channel and all the things my brother
jokes that like just like i am the
productivity guru for various people on
the internet thiago is my personal
productivity guru we talk about a bunch
of things like life organization and
productivity and about the concept of
money and how is how to think about
navigating what you actually want to do
with your life we talk a bunch about
like misunderstandings around what it
means to actually be productive and then
we do a deep dive into the methodology
of building a second brain that will
help you hopefully organize your life
and organize your creative output
whether that's in your work or in your
personal life so i hope you enjoy this
conversation between me and thiago forte
this is gonna be an interesting
conversation so this is the first time
you and i are meeting in the flesh yes
i've been following your stuff for the
last three years now and i remember the
moment where i discovered you it was my
brother who actually recommended your
stuff to me saying that look ali you
know how you are the productivity guru
for all these people on your youtube
channel tiago should be your
productivity guru and i was like cool i
went on forte labs and i binged all of
the blog posts and all that stuff took
the course building a second brain and
then we've been kind of friends on
twitter for the last like three years
yeah um and on very zoom calls here and
there
uh so much stuff to talk to you about i
think your journey is pretty inspiring
we'll talk about the blog we'll talk
about productivity and creativity but
the place i wanted to start with is that
you recently became a dad yes and you
have another child on the way and i
cannot imagine what
quote like her being a parent does and
like stress tests your time management
and like productivity systems so like
how did
i guess you you were a productivity bro
before being a dad and now you're a
productivity bro meets a dad what was
the difference between these two modes
of operation
oh my gosh yeah um became a dad about 18
months ago um
it just
radically
constrains your time energy attention
bandwidth all of it
in in multiple ways i mean
obviously you want to spend hours a day
this is something i would not have
guessed
i can't it's painful to be away from my
kid for a day
like i wouldn't think that that would be
true of me i thought you know i i can go
on trips i can i don't know go on
business trips but i need to see him
every day if i don't it's painful it
hurts and so now suddenly i have an
hours a day commitment but a commitment
that i i love i really enjoy
um which is such a contrasted before
where you know before having a kid
before getting married especially i just
had unlimited if i wanted to stay up all
night and just you know binge learn
something i did if i wanted to spend the
whole weekend doing something i did
there were almost no constraints on my
time i'd say that's the biggest
difference and how does that like i mean
you know obviously you're a parent now
you're trying to juggle this like
business that you've got as well writing
a book
what what effect does this kind of big
thing in your life i.e wife and kid have
on the other aspects of your life i'm
asking selfishly because i'm very
curious as to how because already i feel
like oh i don't have enough time yeah
but then i think but i don't even have a
kid like come on i've been easy
yeah it's it's difficult to imagine the
transition before it happens um but i
think
it's it's hard it's it's painful because
it's just so much change
you just have a way you're you're used
to spending your time and it has to all
change but i think now you know
approaching two years in it's it was
helpful uh it's actually interesting the
having the kid coincided almost
perfectly with hiring a team
with hiring people and you know i've
always heard the advice oh you need to
delegate you need to outsource you need
to you know pick the five percent what
is the five percent that the one percent
most valuable stuff but until you
actually need to you don't do that like
you think you do but when you only have
say 90 minutes in a work day
it's this moment of truth where you have
to you have to look yourself in the
mirror and just be so honest
right like what actually is going to
make a difference what is going to move
the needle in my career and my business
and often it's it's a very different
answer than you'd expect so i think
overall basically to answer your
question it's been a forcing function
it's been a helpful constraint where i
just wake up in the morning and i have
to
ask myself and answer what is the number
one thing that i need to get done today
and just focus all of my attention on
that ah okay because i kind of do this i
ask myself what's the number one thing i
need to get done today but then i
actually have quite a lot of time to do
the thing yes or and and it's actually
on days where the calendar is
chock-a-block with something yes this
conversation or the the video we just
did for the channels and and so on where
it's like oh crap
make progress on chapter one of my book
or write 500 words yeah i only have this
30 minute blog to do this in yeah and
then it gets done like parkinson's law
and yes but when i had the whole day for
filming a video it takes the whole day
to film the video exactly it's it's
really true
um so
changing gears a little bit um one thing
i'd like to ask guess is
how did we get here
how did you and i end up sitting across
from each other and you end up being one
of the world's most foremost experts on
productivity what was the journey
yeah i mean first of all i just i just
wrote that
uh i just you know almost aspirationally
in fact very aspirationally maybe three
four years ago said who who do i want to
be how do i want to present myself to
the world and i wrote that it wasn't
true at the time but it's something
funny about kind of credibility and
expertise
if certain people say it it's true
and that's true of something like one of
the world's foremost experts now that
it's that's been printed in the new york
times in the harvard business review on
radio shows and podcasts and different
youtube channels it's kind of it's
become a self-fulfilling prophecy um but
how that happened i don't know how how
far back do you want to go so what did
you do at uh after school
yes let's see i studied business um so i
graduated in 2009 okay 2000 end of 2008
2009 which if you remember in the us was
the financial meltdown the financial
implosion
so there were no jobs there were no
possibilities i had no particular skill
i really like i'm not just saying this i
really had no particular
thing that i was uniquely good at i'd
studied business which is kind of just
like the standard thing to do
uh and so i joined the peace corps oh
are you familiar with the peace corps no
what is that i've heard of it but yeah
it's a it's a us government agency
basically
that's existed since the 70s or late 60s
that basically
pays u.s volunteers of all ages to go to
usually developing countries and serve
for two years i was there two years and
three months so i went to eastern
ukraine
the far eastern portion of ukraine near
the russian border and this is very
random but i was an english teacher
there at a high school combined middle
school high school
for two years when i was in my early
twenties mid-twenties okay so it's like
you were at this point where you didn't
really know what to do with your life
exactly let's do this thing yeah it
seems kind of cool so what what happened
next time that's exactly what it was i
had no idea what i wanted to do there
was nothing that seemed particularly
appealing and so i just thought how can
i how can i extend the student lifestyle
where someone just tells me what to do
for a couple more years that's what the
peace corps was okay um and it wasn't it
was an amazing experience it was
challenging i mean you have those
siberian style winters you know i'm from
california to me before ukraine a cold
winter was like oh it's in the 50s 50s
fahrenheit i don't know what that is
celsius
but i i had no experience of real
winters so that was challenging i was in
the town completely by myself the peace
corps doesn't want americans to be in
the same place because then they just
hang out together all the time so i was
the only american only english speaker
from many miles around
and i think what i learned is i learned
that i like teaching i was an english
teacher so i was you know i had a day
job i would go every day to the school
and teach you know from third grade to
11th grade so i had experience teaching
from
really kids all the way to you know near
adults
i learned that i loved teaching i
learned um
actually that was the first time i i
taught kind of productivity related
things
at the time it was it was basically
study skills okay because i would go
into these classrooms and you know the
ukrainian which is basically like a
legacy soviet education system is so old
school like until you've experienced
what a decades-old school system is like
it's it's very different there was no
concept of study skills it was just
everything was pure rote memorization
everything was just this is the teacher
talking at you for the whole class
period memorize it regurgitate it for
the test
and so i started teaching you know how
to take notes how to set goals even just
like for your class how to make a
schedule like imagine a student who has
never had to make a schedule never had
to look at their agenda
and i just saw what a tremendous
difference it made you know just as one
example i would teach my 10th and 11th
formers uh how to do these things and
then they would use those skills to
apply to university get into university
which is a completely life-changing you
know
um life-changing thing for them and so
that combination of kind of productivity
study skills project management with
teaching
really started to spark something in me
during those two years oh okay and i
guess that's that's when like the word
productivity i feel like hasn't like
would have become popular after that
time
so how how were you thinking about it
when you were teaching these things yeah
that's a good point i didn't think of it
as productivity productivity at the time
i didn't know i wasn't familiar with
this whole world of thought leaders and
blogs none of that you know i was only
24 years old i hadn't had any exposure
and so i i came back from ukraine
uh to get my first sort of real
professional job in san francisco and i
so i went from you know a village in
eastern rural ukraine straight to the
epicenter of silicon valley in a matter
of like a couple months it's a complete
culture shock reverse culture shock
right which in some ways is harder than
culture shock you go to eastern europe
you expect i'm gonna have some
difficulty you come back to california
you know i came back to my home state
and i i just remember most of all being
just
so shocked by the pace of work
you know we were in a co-working space
in downtown san francisco surrounded by
startups
it was it was the quintessential
information overload the speed at which
communication happened email happened
collaboration happened was completely
foreign to me at that time okay what
what do you mean by that like the pace
of pace of work it was just so fast i
mean in the morning we'd have a meeting
someone has an idea
then the hour after the meeting they
write it up and then midday at lunch
they're discussing the next iteration
and then by the afternoon it might be
written up in a document that is shared
with colleagues around the world
and to do all that it wasn't just going
fast you had to absorb a lot of
information manage a lot of information
keep track of a lot of information so
around this time i was introduced to
productivity apps i was introduced to
digital notetaking apps evernote and
others i was introduced really to social
media i had been on like you know
facebook and things like that before but
it was such a crash course in just what
it means to be
a knowledge worker and kind of just like
a modern information-centric person yeah
and i guess if i think of kind of most
jobs these days
it is that kind of knowledge work where
really there's information flying at you
from all angles even even in medicine to
be honest like a big chunk of the way i
operated as a doctor was using
productivity principles to figure out
like prioritization and to-do list
management and figuring out my schedule
for the day being like okay from one to
two i've got a teaching block i know the
ward round is from eight till eleven so
between eleven and one i need to do this
list of jobs let's figure out the ones
that rely on other people being in
bottleneck like getting radiology to
approve my scan request first and then
okay cool let's do the stuff that
requires waiting on things yeah and so i
almost have like a waiting for list on
my little page yeah um started using the
ipad people would always be like oh
using your ipad what's that like yeah um
and it seems like more and more jobs are
actually about managing knowledge and
managing information flows
i think that's that's mostly what jobs
are these days is your if you boil it
down to the most basic elements you have
inputs you process those inputs and turn
them into outputs
and you can map this to to literally any
job any kind of work
which is cool because once you you you
sort of boil it down to that level you
can learn from anyone you can look at
chefs and i've i've learned a tremendous
amount from chefs you can look at
construction my brother's a construction
manager a contractor i learned things
from him i've talked to truck drivers
musicians comedians at when at the most
basic level of inputs and outputs we're
all doing the exact same thing and
therefore we can all learn from each
other um yeah it reminds me that this um
uh bertrand russell has an essay in
praise of idleness where he talks about
um how and he wrote this in like the
1930s or something like that uh maybe in
the 1910s about how how the modern world
is obsessed with productivity yeah and
he
was writing this 100 years ago and he
was saying well what is the definition
of a job a job is moving matter
or above the earth's surface or telling
other people to do that
and i think and then our friend paul
millet expanded on that definition or
which is like either moving matter or
moving pixels or telling other people to
move matter or pixels yeah at the earth
surface basically what we're doing is
jobs we built our whole lives around
this kind of construct of our job and
our whole identities around you know me
feeling like oh my god i don't have a
job like once i leave medicine what am i
gonna do like who am i all of these
things is basically either moving
something from a to b or moving a pixel
from a to b
i'm telling other people to do that it's
so true it's kind of crazy that that is
our jobs that is what we do we have to
become experts in these weird esoteric
fields you know like something like you
know personal knowledge management or ux
design or
you know uh
these different methodologies like agile
or scrum
these used to be such a rarified
abstract for like academics and like
universities now you know there's
actually power and dabbling in those
things and applying them yeah because i
think i think the thing that's
interesting about that that basic level
of inputs and outputs is that there's so
much variation in how well people do
that
there's orders of magnitude variation
you think it's just inputs outputs but
there's clearly if you just look at the
economy look at the world there's some
people that do it very badly and some
people that do it astronomically well so
in this episode thiago and i talked a
lot about the idea of productivity
there's one productivity book in
particular in addition to of course
building a second brain tiago's book
that i've really enjoyed over the last
few months and that is four thousand
weeks time and how to use it by oliver
berkman who we in fact had as a guest on
the previous season of deep dive so you
can check that out that'll be linked
down below and in the show notes it's
genuinely a really good book and it's
all about kind of the finitude of time
and it's about like existentialism and
it's about like what is the point of all
this productivity and it just takes a
little bit more of a a balanced and
uplifting and nice view of the whole
productivity thing but if you want to
get the key ideas from the book and
maybe you don't quite have time to read
the book in its entirety you might like
to check out the summary of the book
over a short form who are very kindly
sponsoring this episode of the podcast
if you haven't heard by now short form
is the world's best book summary service
it's way better than all of the other
competitors who i shall not name that
i've tried out over the years and it's
way more than just book summaries so
they've got one pagers for every book on
the in the catalog but they also have
detailed chapter by chapter summaries so
you can dive deeper into it and the
other cool thing is that they also have
these little short form notes so for
example if the author of a book makes a
particular point if that point is
particularly controversial or there's an
author of a different book who's argued
against that point then short form will
flag that up within the summary itself
with a little short form note so they'll
say for example that hey if you've read
a grit by angela duckworth you'll find
that she argues the exact opposite of
what oliver birkman is arguing for in
4000 weeks and it's just really nice
because it gives you a balanced
perspective rather than just imagining
that a single author's word just because
it's packaged up in book format is
gospel truth the way i use short form
personally is that firstly if i get a
book recommendation and i'm not 100 sold
on reading the book immediately then i
will look up the summary of it on short
form and based on how i feel about the
summary then i will decide whether i do
or don't want to read the book i also
use it because it's a great way of
revisiting things i've learned from
books i've already read so for example
my two main ways of doing that are
number one rereading my kindle
highlights which is all the stuff that
personally resonated with me but it's
also really useful to read the short
form summary to see if there's anything
that i've missed or any particular
particularly interesting point that has
sparked some kind of thought that
resonates with something i read recently
it's just genuinely good for getting a
detailed summary of the thing that i can
then follow up on if i want if any of
that sums up your stream then head over
to short form dot com forward slash deep
dive and that url will give you a 20
discount on the annual premium
subscription so yeah thank you so much
short form for sponsoring this episode
of the podcast i want to
talk a little bit about
the concept of productivity because
in a way
you know and i guess you and i are very
sort of plugged into this particular
ecosystem and so we can maybe see the
trend but it seems like the world has or
at least the people we follow on twitter
has sort of moved away from productivity
and now i feel a little bit like uh when
you know i was i was interviewed on a
podcast and they thought that they
called me a productivity expert yeah oh
i guess so okay fine fair enough now i
am a guy i guess i'm a productivity
expert but also a lot of people seem to
be like oh well what's the point of
productivity like yeah life is about
more than just productivity kind of kind
of thing like how how do you approach
the word productivity which i think has
industrial age kind of connotations of
cranking out more and more widgets yeah
so a couple things first i like
industrial age stuff
one of my biggest sources of inspiration
has been modern manufacturing the theory
of constraints just in time
manufacturing um you know high velocity
manufacturing automated manufacturing i
think sometimes we disparage that stuff
to our you know to our detriment um mod
manufacturing today is not you know like
in the 1920s these dirty soot-filled you
know exploitative
factories
it is it is something much different
it's very precise it's very
technology-centric it's very
collaborative
um so i don't i don't mind using
factories as a kind of metaphor
but to kind of answer your question more
directly i think of productivity as a
phase
it's a phase phase in someone's life
okay there is a phase in your life or it
could recur so there could be different
phases where you have to think about
productivity and then there's other
phases where you think about creativity
i really see productivity and creativity
as two sides to the same coin
and where i learned about this was from
my dad my dad is one of the most
creative people i've ever met wildly
imaginative creative
but how does that creativity make it out
into the world is productivity so he has
these these very systematic approaches
and routines and rules that he uses from
you know the time of day that he paints
from this time to this time to how long
he's going to spend on each stage of a
painting to the way that he takes notes
and so i see this kind of like pendulum
productivity creativity productivity
creativity and if you go too far on
either end of the spectrum
you start hitting diminishing returns
then you start to get stuck right like
like on both sides you can get so
fixated on productivity
your work starts to become formulaic it
starts to become very boring and it's
time to to kind of go to the other end
of the spectrum creativity but then you
can go too far in creativity that's when
you get too precious
you get to oh no that's my art it has to
be a certain way and you know you talk
to someone six months later what are you
doing oh i'm working on my my one
painting for the last six months that
also doesn't work you're not you're
getting stuck you're getting you're
getting sort of locked up in your own
preciousness and so i i really see them
as this kind of alternating back and
forth pendulum nice yeah i had a bit of
thought as you were saying that and i
think
i've never really thought of the two as
being being separate i get i i guess
you know given that a bunch of videos i
make happen to be vaguely themed around
productivity when people ask me oh what
is productivity to you i kind of take a
step back i broaden it out and i say oh
productivity just using your time
intentionally yeah um which then makes
it a more like gentle definition that
you can apply to your personal life to
your work life and who doesn't want to
use the time more intentionally yeah but
there's something about the word
productivity that feels a bit more like
ugh
it feels very worky yeah and very much
like i'm generating economic output for
my employer and this is a bad thing yeah
um any any thoughts on that yeah a
couple things um
so productivity is like efficiency
efficiency is sort of a synonym right
what is efficiency if you again if you
go back to manufacturing it's simply
minimizing waste that's how i think of
it
which is
one of the most important things in life
like when people say productivity
doesn't matter i go does it not matter
that you not waste your time you know
does it not matter that you waste your
attention does it not matter that you
waste your ideas does it not matter that
you waste your potential
like isn't that like almost what life is
about and it's easy to lose sight of
that if you think of efficiency but i
really just think about it as minimizing
waste
and then the other thing i was going to
say oh think about other uses of the
word productivity a productive
conversation
would you say a productive conversation
is
is you know not is uh
is anti-human or is not benevolent or is
kind of removing the humanity no i want
all my the most intimate conversation
with my wife i still want to be
productive that doesn't mean it's not a
good conversation
or alternatively think of a productive
ecosystem
productive ecosystem the forest is a
productive ecosystem not because we went
in and clear-cut everything and built a
parking lot but because there is value
being created right and you could say
economic value but i just think of
there's plants being grown there's
animals that are surviving there's
evolution that's happening there's
families animals and humans that are
being raised from the sustenance of the
forest so i kind of like to to use the
word productivity because it confronts
people that's what i like
i want people to be confronted okay
because the same thing that has you kind
of be triggered by productivity
if you follow that thread you're gonna
get to
an incorrect assumption a limiting
belief a blind spot that is going to
limit you in life and in your career
oh that is beautiful i can feel my kind
of mindset changing about that because
i've also been like yeah i agree
productivity is a bit of a dirty word so
let's not use that word let's call it
intentionality or something like that
but i like how you're just like yep
productivity
is a good thing like of course it's a
good thing um
interesting um
okay so again when people like uh the
the anti-productivity movement seems to
treat productivity as being all about
work in particular
and would say that oh but like
personal life and wellness and like
self-care is like really really
important and like
stuff
do you think of the separation of
productivity as being like work versus
personal life or like how do you think
about it
yeah you know
i think
you know being productive is ultimately
about having a a career you love
i mean you're not going to get the jobs
you want you're not going to start the
business you want you're not going to
advance if you're not productive you're
just not it's wishful thinking and so
you have to learn it and then go beyond
it
but the way i think of this too is um
you know most of my 20s i was working in
non-profits i worked for a microfinance
nonprofit in colombia
during university as part of my study
abroad i taught english in brazil and
then later in ukraine
i worked for the government in the peace
corps so like a majority of my 20s i was
a bleeding heart humanitarian i was
going to dedicate my life to just to
service really that's what i wanted to
do but i i became disillusioned with
that whole idea because i saw and i
studied i really looked into the numbers
like what actually makes a difference in
people's lives what knowledge what
training what sometimes it's called
capacity building or whatever it is and
honestly you can boil it down to one
thing
if you want to improve
someone's life life outcomes all of them
increase their income
increase their income if you can
raise that one dial
the downstream effect that they will
take care of all the rest they'll
improve their health their family will
be healthier they'll improve their
neighborhood they'll improve their
psychology they'll invest in education
it's almost like people can be trusted
people know what's best for them but
they need the resources
so i made this hard pivot i thought
business for years was evil was bad i'm
not going to do business i made this
hard pivot from like humanitarian stuff
into business because i just thought i'm
going to focus all my attention on
helping people have amazing careers and
amazing businesses because that's how
they raise their income and then
everything else is going to be
positively impacted
interesting
how did you get to that knowledge that
that conclusion that the thing that
matters is raising people's income
because i've not heard that idea before
i've heard like oh the thing that
matters is education for girls yeah
raising the whatever of a country or the
thing that matters is sanitation or
vaccination or all these things like
what
what lands your income
yeah this might be a bit controversial i
don't even know i don't know if anyone
if everyone would agree with that um but
where it really came from was my
research in microfinance
microphone is funny because it is it's
not it's a non-profit it's humanitarian
it's you know development work but it's
also finance
and all the research that's been done
there's some there's actually some major
problems with microfinance but there's
some very clear research that
you know people if they just have loans
like what is more mercenary than loans
what is more like oh yeah like eve oh my
gosh loans that have finance charges and
you're charging them interest and yet
for a lot of people microfinance has had
a tremendous impact uh i guess it just
comes from seeing that in action you
know i worked for a nonprofit in
colombia in the coastal region of
cartagena which is the poorest part of
colombia and one of the poorest parts of
latin america
and our loans were like fifty dollars
a hundred dollars few hundred dollars
they just needed a little like by our
standards like we spend that much on a
dinner or like a lunch right and they
would make investments they would buy
you know a cart for their business they
would send their kids to school
for a month or two they would they would
make these little changes that then had
cascading effects um and i guess it's
just something i observed that that
increasing your like
it's i think very well established that
hot higher incomes are correlated and i
think causal from all these other things
right like how are you going to improve
your health if you don't have money if
you have zero financial resources what
are you gonna do like you just don't
have that many options
i love that that's great like i've you
know since
over the last year or two my youtube
channel has taken a soft pivot rather
than a hard pivot a lot towards talking
about like business and entrepreneurship
and making money
and i will occasionally get comments
from people being like i liked your
youtube channel when you were talking
about how to study for your exams yeah
but now all you talk about is how to
make money yeah this is bad yeah i've
always kind of thought that like they're
right in that that is now the thing that
i talk about
but like the way i see it that you know
i'm i'm all about kind of helping people
to live their best lives and me trying
to do that myself and hopefully trying
to be a sort of a documentarian of what
i'm doing to live my best life so the
people can as well
and like without without having money
it's like what do you
what are you gonna do yeah you know in
in the sort of the first world problem
that me and most of my close friends
have is like oh you know i want to be
self-actualized i want my job to meet
with the thing that i enjoy i don't want
to be a wage slave
my my housemate um you know works works
14 hours a day for management consulting
and she's like yeah it's fun but like
it's it's too many hours i can't live my
best life because i'm spending all that
time with my employer yeah and she
started the youtube channel started a
podcast started a business trying to do
business coaching on the side to build
up these streams of income
to buy her the freedom to then
use her life energy the limited time we
have on this earth yeah on something
that she actually wants to do i.e
helping women's education yeah rather
than trying to make a rich management
consultant company a little bit richer
yeah and without money and and so i
think it's very easy to
um
it's very easy to cast shade on people
that talk about money yeah thinking that
like oh evil capitalist off making money
is just about exploiting the poor or
whatever terminology people use for this
but actually like making money is how
you
raise this every everything else every
sample of society that we live in it's
what you just say money is that the most
fungible resource it's the easiest thing
to exchange for anything else
even more than time yeah because money
you you need anyway to just live to
survive so if you're going to do that
anyway i mean money can be exchanged for
freedom like you said it can be
exchanged for connections it can be
exchanged for i mean the other thing
that i really care a lot about and
invest a lot of time in is personal
development and personal development is
so expensive even something like this is
a great example
of a pasana meditation retreat yep it's
free
anywhere in the world there's centers
all over free 100 free no cost
but they're 10 days
for you to take 10 days off from work
and and like offload your
responsibilities so no so you don't have
to be in touch with anyone because you
have no phone
that's more that's
hard to even calculate the monetary
value of that so even for something that
is free you spend a lot of time in
uh and so i just think money is this
kind of base layer it's this kind of
basic security that uni it's like
maslow's you know hierarchy you need a
certain foundation to be able to invest
in freedom self-development creativity
productivity all these other things
depend on your income interesting i need
to stop saying what interesting people
keep telling me i use the word
interesting too much um
so there's a book on that bookshelf
called happy sexy millionaire by stephen
bartlett um is this um
yeah um
podcast hoster a podcast host
entrepreneur um based in the uk
and he has a phrase that health is your
first foundation
because like without health there is
nothing else and there's no point having
loads of money if you don't have the
health
and the thing that you just said almost
sounds as if money is your first
foundation
and i i wonder
like i'm just thinking out loud here but
i i wonder to what extent it's like
once you have sufficient money
then at that point health becomes your
first foundation but if you don't it's
very hard to take care of your health
when you literally broke because like
yeah how are you gonna find the time to
do the healthy things and yeah eat the
healthy meal and to cook the whole food
in your own place yeah when you're
trying to work multiple jobs to make
ends meet yeah i mean i think there's
definitely like a flywheel they're
synergistic with each other but yeah
yeah being healthy is expensive
the healthier the food the more
expensive it is and the the worse the
food is for you the cheaper it is which
is like if you were going to design an
unhealthy society that's how you would
do it make the worst stuff cheap and
easy and convenient and fast and
everywhere and make the the healthy
stuff difficult to access
easy to spoil expensive and so it takes
it takes a real investment to kind of
get over to this side
but but i mean obviously too to make
money you also need to have a certain
level of kind of biological you know
stability
yeah yeah i think it comes to comes to
that law of uh equal and opposite advice
that like for different people in
different situations
the exact opposite advice may well work
absolutely so for someone like me and
you probably we should probably focus on
our health yeah more than making more
money yes but when we were in our early
days when we were in our early 20s
trying to sort of hustle and or whatever
at that point actually optimizing for
making money is
is is not the worst thing you could do
yeah and spending the time cooking
healthy foods yeah going to the gym and
all that kind of stuff okay fine but
like you know there are things at
different points in our lives
certain things become more needle-moving
than others yes and i think for me and
this is the thing i encourage a lot of
people to do
getting productive becoming really good
at your job becoming really good at your
studies becoming really good at work
becoming really good at the thing that
you're doing to then start a business to
build up potential streams of income
yeah that is actually a really good
thing to be doing when you're young plus
it's really really fun as well
i couldn't agree more i i really think
in terms of seasons also you know like
when i learn about whatever topic let's
say it's productivity i don't want to be
like a productivity fan you know i don't
want to like just casually once in a
while as if it's as if it's like i don't
know like like perusing a magazine like
oh this is entertaining
pick a pick a goal pick a skill you want
to learn concentrate on it intensively
immerse yourself in in it for a short
amount of time and then go do something
else that's the whole point is you
acquire skill and then you step away and
use it elsewhere yeah because i guess
the thing about productivity is that
it's not an end in itself it is like a
means to the end of the thing that you
want i.e helping you just do the things
you want yeah and similarly creativity
is not an end in itself it's
a tool to help you do the things that
you want in the world have the impact
live a happy meaningful life whatever
people's goals are which are broadly
aligned with those things yeah um and
that's you know as we said going too far
in one direction or another
you're in a way that there is a danger
of worshiping at the altar of the tool
yes rather than the thing that the tool
lets you do yeah like being a hammer
enthusiast rather than being a carpenter
or something like that
a hammer enthusiast i have the world's
greatest collection of hammers what have
you built oh no this just is i just
collect hammers
that's fine people who collect hammers
but like it would be hard to argue that
that has you know
and unless that's the thing they act
they genuinely want to do i find this
with like no taking apps i fall into the
pattern of like oh let's try this one
let's try that one and i become
the collector of note-taking apps rather
than actually writing which is and
putting it out into the world which is
the thing i actually care about
absolutely
um so we were in the process of your
journey so you've so you joined some
went back to san francisco let's say
you're in your sort of early to late 20s
and you said that you made this hard
pivot from the humanitarian stuff to the
business stuff what was the story behind
that pivot how did that happen i had
like i said no business and money
investing
uh
productivity business none of this but
my mom gave me one night rich dad poor
dad oh yeah rich dad poor dad changed
everything because it was my first
exposure i was like i was like
you know someone in the desert finding
water
i didn't know that's what i was missing
i i was missing a relationship too in
that case money coming back to the
subject of money which was a
relationship of abundance you know as
long as i thought that money was evil
business was bad everything in that
world was bad i was
those are some of the most
like most powerful forces in the world
right and so i read that book i read the
whole book in one night i couldn't sleep
the entire night read it through the
night
and i just kind of was in a daze and i
just thought oh my gosh business this is
what i realized from reading it business
can be the vehicle
for everything that i want to create in
the world for the impact the positive
impact i want to have the people i want
to help the education i want to create
the life outcomes for people that i want
to i want to change business can be my
friend instead of my enemy and i made a
complete life pivot uh went went from
from studying international development
in school to studying international
business
uh started you know writing uh started
writing and publishing my first little
bits of content online i really just
chose business as my means for
for having the impact i wanted to have
why do so many people
seemingly at least the ones who are
active on twitter uh why do they feel so
like anti-business
i think it's our arts our conditioning
that's what we were taught
yeah that making money people have so
many i'm sure you see this all the time
so many limiting beliefs around making
money um you know making money means you
are compromising your integrity
making money means you're taking
advantage of people making money means
you are losing yourself and not being
authentic like there's some belief and
we all have these we never actually
completely let go of all those beliefs
they're lurking back here in our
psychology
um but those things you know they have
truth in them but they're not the truth
yeah like money is the root of all evil
yeah kind of stuff yeah
yeah i remember two years ago now a year
and a half ago
i had a call with you and our mutual
friend david about uh this course that i
was i was gonna start the part-time
youtuber academy and i was thinking oh
you know i'll do it as a pre-recorded
thing i'll sell it for like 200 why
don't we partner up on it because i
don't like the idea of selling it myself
but if i sell it with you then it's like
it makes it okay
and what you and david were both kind of
laughing it was like it sounds like you
think making money is evil yeah it
sounds like you think selling something
is evil yeah but what if that's not true
and you sort of challenged me to
question my assumptions around that yeah
that actually what is money money is an
exchange of value yeah and if you're
providing something that is valuable and
doing it in a way that's like authentic
and with integrity and stuff yeah and
people pay you for it that's literally
how the world runs yeah and that is not
an evil thing
and there are so many creators that i
speak to now that i i recount that
conversation to when they're like ah
it's okay for me to get to do a
sponsored video sponsored by squarespace
or brilliant or skillshare whoever
happens to be sponsoring this episode um
but as soon as i sell my own product
suddenly that becomes oh i i couldn't do
that yeah my audience would hate me for
becoming a sellout for selling my own
thing yeah yeah
it's so common it's so common and the
internet almost makes this worse because
you can just create free stuff forever
and you'll get paid somehow maybe like
sponsorships or you know ads or
something
but
it's just a certain business model that
we both found
finding the most engaged people who are
building their own businesses can can
really be a great business and really
impactful for them like we were talking
before recording that
someone can hear a piece of advice a
hundred times but then you look them in
the eye and you say do x
x is the right path for you and suddenly
they're like oh wow that really sunk in
it's the power of teaching it's the
power of coaching it's the power of
interactive you know forums
yeah
nice
so
we're i guess at this point we're in
your early 30s you've made this pivot to
business
how do you go from
kind of humanitarian bro to kind of
business bro to world's foremost
productivity expert what was the journey
there there were a couple steps in
between
yeah so let's see i it took me years it
took me years because i you know had
that first
uh professional job in san francisco
which was in consulting learn so much
through consulting consulting is great
for young people also because you just
get exposure to so many different kinds
of businesses every month there's a
different client and so one day you're
in you know petroleum refine refinement
another uh month you're in like
self-driving cars another month you're
in something completely different
packaged goods
and so i kind of had this broad exposure
to different businesses
the one i liked the most by far was
education right that's just what i loved
uh and i quit that job one day when i
just couldn't take it anymore i wish i
could say i had a plan but it was like
rage quit like i just can't take this
um and the reason for that was i just
remember putting in more hours than i
had ever put into anything i mean
consulting is brutal you work just
absurdly long days you work late into
the night you work on weekends you
travel and work even longer
and i just realized wait a minute i can
keep doing this for years and i remember
i had my first performance review i
always tell the story
the first time someone had ever sat down
and talked about my career what do you
want for your career it was great but
then they my manager laid out the path
and and she was like okay a couple more
years you can go from junior project
manager to project manager a couple
years after that senior project manager
a few few more years after that see you
know
project director and she was laying it
out like like it was so inspiring and
amazing and i was like
my god i'm going to waste the most
productive decade of my life
to climb this career ladder i might as
well do that for my own stuff and invest
in my own my own stuff and so i quit
um and that that started kind of the the
self-employment journey
how did you just quit
i mean this is the privilege of being
single childless
uh i really had very little savings um
so
i
you do you mean like how i did it
financially or like how i actually did
it yeah i felt like the financial thing
because like oh just quit your job yeah
it's that's
i i'm i ask because i i feel like every
other person i meet me these days is
like i'm thinking of quitting my job
yeah i'm like great and they're like oh
but money yeah you know what i think
living abroad had really taught me how
just how little i can get by on
it is really something i think you have
to learn for yourself
in ukraine i think i survived on like
250 a month was my total budget and of
course that's ukraine right
but you just get creative you learn that
you can rely on other people you learn
that you can make money go so far when
it comes to food
you can crash on people's couches you
can travel cheaply you can have fun
cheaply you don't have to go out to a
posh restaurant you can play a card game
with you know your neighbors
and so i just knew from experience in
the peace corps in colombia in brazil
that i i needed so little financially to
get by of course i was in san francisco
the most one of the most expensive
places in the united states so i think i
had about six weeks of savings i had
about six weeks that i could survive
before i needed new income
which it turns out was the best scenario
if i had had even six months it would
have been bad why because
you know six weeks okay i have two weeks
to plan something two weeks to launch it
and then hope that it makes money within
the last two weeks
that was literally the timeline yeah and
so i just went on skillshare which is
the only
yeah it was skillshare it was the only
online educational platform that i knew
yeah because i didn't have time to do
research i would have spent two weeks
doing research right so i said no let me
just go on skillshare
the only thing that i knew had to teach
was productivity because i had taught it
in the peace corps and this would have
been like like eight seven years ago
before they started sponsoring
everyone's videos yes this was 2013. oh
wow like nine years ago yeah okay so you
went on skillshare yeah it was just when
they were pivoting because skillshare
was originally in person classes okay
they would organize like workshops in
cities and they they decided that's too
hard that's too expensive so they
pivoted online i was in that first wave
which was helpful right uh and i just i
didn't even have time to research
different subjects i just got the
getting things done book which was the
most recent book that i had read like
the the the how little of research and
preparation i did when i look back was
just it was just insane but i just had
no time right it's parkinson's law again
so i just created a course based
directly on this book which i can't
recommend exactly because i almost got
in trouble with the law
i had to put a disclaimer you know this
is not officially approved by the david
allen company so it was fine
uh but that
very first course which i created within
a few weeks ended up doing well and
paying the bills for like a year year
and a half i got very lucky
interesting yeah
okay so were you like what were you
gonna do if things didn't work out in
those six weeks i was probably gonna
move home yeah live on my parents couch
i was starting to look at like local
jobs i applied at target i applied at
like
play you know little retail shops at the
mall i was i had some plans and process
because of course i didn't know it was
gonna work i assumed it was not going to
work
and there was a number of things that
happened that made me get very lucky
like skillshare picked up my course and
promoted it it was like on the front
page of skillshare uh the timing was
really good with productivity stuff
people were really getting interested in
productivity online education was taking
off there were there was a number of
factors that got really lucky but then
also of course it wasn't
i had tried other things kind of like
your story like your first overnight
success
is really like the 10th thing that you
try yeah right um so as a combination of
luck chance timing uh but then i used
that year year and a half it was barely
enough year barely enough money to make
it a year year and a half to to just
really for the next three four years i
just strung together literally like one
or two months of rent at a time i would
go work an event make another few
hundred dollars i would do a random
consulting project for a friend make
another you know couple thousand dollars
i really for a good three or four years
it was like month to month maybe a few
months at a time if i had three months
of rent paid that was like plenty of
runway
and i guess you it it would be kind of
irresponsible to take those sorts of
risks now now that you have like a
family and a kid and stuff to support
yeah so the ability to take those sorts
of asymmetrical risks where the
downside's capped but the upside is
potentially huge
actually it's a lot easier to do when
you're not supporting a family yeah um
like it's yeah it's it's interesting you
say that so one of my one of my close
friends is
you know this
friend working this management
consulting job earning way more than six
figures a year and kind of thing
and she's like uh i know i want to quit
my job but like how will i get back to
that level of income yeah i'm like do
you really need 150k a year to survive
as a single person
when you can just go home and live with
your parents just like oh but i don't
want to do that yeah okay fine but like
if you had to is that like a bad thing
she was like no no it's not really it's
like what are you actually scared of
and it reminds it reminded me of the
story of you know there's that cartoon
of or some kind of uh parable where
there's this kid and their dad and they
go to the zoo
and they see these two elephants one's a
little baby elephant and one's a big
mama elephant and the baby elephant has
a chain a metal chain attached to its
leg and the kid's like daddy why is
there a chain attached to the leg of the
elephant
and the dad's like oh well you know this
you know baby elephants like like to run
around they like to escape and so you
know the chain stops them from escaping
yeah
and then they look at the mama elephant
who's huge and enormous and she's got
this little piece of string yeah
attached to the foot yeah
it's
i think that's such a good like metaphor
for these
invisible shackles these limiting
beliefs that hold us back yes i i run
into this all the time myself from like
oh my god what if the business falls
what if like this and that and then i
speak to someone i was like bro you've
got like 10 years of runway yeah just by
you know i've seen your investment video
you literally have 10 years of runway
i'm like [ __ ] you're right and it's
crazy telling me that in the next 10
years you won't be able to figure
something out it's crazy like why do you
need 150k a year to live like you can
literally just move back home or hang
out with friends and make something
happen yeah
i it really is true it's um
you know the fact that
my salary at that consulting job was so
low it was criminally low like it was
barely survivable in san francisco was a
blessing because i had nothing to lose
you know i'm just going to go from one
subsistence salary to another
subsistence salary
and so i think unique constraints like
the best way to destroy someone's
motivation and productivity and momentum
give them a ton of money give them a ton
of time give them a ton of freedom
when you have an overabundance of those
things you just start floating in space
because there's no hard line
there's no wall there's no constraint
for you to push up against and and for
that's going to force you to kind of
make a make a choice yeah
yeah this reminds me of something i read
in a business book recently around like
kind of building startups and stuff
where it's kind of the idea that um
before a business has figured out their
money printing machine
it's very exhilarating very very like
all hands on deck we need to we need to
make this happen there is a sense of
urgency a sense of energy about the
place as soon as the business has
figured out what its money printing
machine is and now they scale and now
they get more people on board yeah
suddenly you start caring about [ __ ]
things like yeah oh i want everyone to
only be working six hours a day i want
to make sure we have bean bags wanna
make sure we have massages at work and
all this kind of stuff yeah and you
often hear from people that the early
days were in a way more fun than the
scaling days when we had the table
tennis table and the bean bag and all
the perks that you could you could dream
for yes because there is this sense of
urgency when you're like i need to make
this work yeah and once it's working you
know then it's a lot it's very easy to
just be like oh life is good that's very
true that's why you want to live life um
but i think there is then a danger of
you know a lot of big businesses move so
much slower than smaller businesses a
lot of big businesses are at risk of
potentially failing because they don't
have that momentum that a scrappy
startup does absolutely i think that
same kind of principle applies to our
personal lives as well yeah that there
is a level of like keeping up the
scrappiness yeah which is just generally
fun as long as it doesn't overly burn
you out and stress you out to the point
where it's like chronic over such a long
period of time yes but there is some
energy in you know the idea of hormesis
and you know what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger
a little bit of calorie restriction is
good for the body a little bit of sleep
deprivation is good for us a little bit
of like having to run
and like be in a stress situation is
good for us yeah um whereas if we're a
couch potato with a catheter and like a
video game controller all day living a
very comfortable life um then you know
there's not much progress there yeah
it's it's very true
um so
what what was it in your journey that
then caused things to quote take off as
it were
how did you move away from the
subsistence subsistence living
month-to-month kind of lifestyle
yeah so it's it kind of slowly changed
and i tried
i tried so many things
for a while
i thought let me go into consulting
because that has super low overhead
right it's just one person
didn't wasn't very good at that didn't
enjoy it much then i went into corporate
training because i thought i know how to
teach
that was more profitable that's when the
money started getting better but
i was just in these environments working
in silicon valley for some of the you
know
wealthiest corporations in the world and
i lost the humanitarian
service side right i was working you
know for these companies just making the
world's wealthiest companies even
wealthier which is no problem with that
remember as we were saying
but it just wasn't very satisfying i
needed to work with people who were just
starting out people who were in need
people who had a problem
um and so so but at the same time i was
taking elements of all these things like
from consulting even though it didn't
really work i learned how to talk to
companies that's a skill to be able to
come into a business meeting and have a
business conversation right i learned
how to price things i learned just how
much money corporations have and how
much they're willing to spend without
you know without that difficult of a
process
from corporate training i learned how to
structure you know trainings i learned
how to design workshops i learned how to
uh to deliver content in a way that a
professional uh could take in and take
seriously
but then i went to online education
actually even online education didn't
really work because i had had that first
gtd self-paced course and so i thought
oh this is my jam the first my first try
was a success i i'm a master well the
second and third and fourth attempts
failed
because gtd has a built-in audience has
a built-in it's a movement and so
there's like a ready-made demand um i
had much more difficulty in fact i i
haven't to this day launched another
successful self-paced course so that
also was not my skill i didn't have the
production capabilities i didn't have
the planning capabilities
and so i just kept trying things trying
to find my niche and it ended up being
the most
you know something i would have never
guessed which was cohort based courses
was taking the business stuff from
consulting the training from corporate
training the teaching of self-paced
courses combining all of them into an
online course but one that is delivered
live via zoom in a way that doesn't
require so much polish it doesn't
require so much preparation because i'm
not good at that
but was all about the human connection
and about interaction and coaching
through zune
wow and i guess all of that has now
culminated in this book
yes building second brain a proven
method to un organize your digital life
and unlock your creative potential like
how long have you been running the
course well what's been the what was the
story of kind of the the course and it's
sort of growth yeah so it's wild because
i never i never made long-term plans for
this i never tried i never thought much
into the future i really just ran one
cohort at a time
so i did a like a beta cohort in like
december 2016.
uh cohort one the first official cohort
was like january february 2017. uh and
now is this now we're in the the spring
summer 2022 we've done 14 cohorts which
is just insane to me like i really the
same way earlier that i went from pa
from paycheck to paycheck and then one
month's rent to the next month's rent i
was kind of used to that i was used to
very short term you know finances
i really for the first like
seven eight nine cohorts it was just to
make enough money in this cohort to run
the next one that's all i thought about
until very recently
and it just kept going each cohort a
little bit better a little more
profitable a little bit bigger
until i could you know afford to do
things like hire a team and hire higher
people how did you get your first few
customers
it was all friends okay it was i think i
i had a personal relationship with every
single person in the first cohort it was
like
colleagues former co-workers people in
that co-working space that i had met
over lunch
friends exes
i just went into my social network and
was like any favor that i have yeah and
it really was them doing me a favor
those early cohorts i i'm sorry i'm
sorry to those people because it was i
would just show up on a zoom call maybe
with some slides yeah it was just
extemporaneous it was it was improvised
uh around cohort six seven or eight i
started to really have pride in what we
were doing
how much were you charging in the early
days
so it started at 500 500 yeah which was
cohort one which is a huge
does that sound cheap or expensive that
sounds really expensive it was yeah
right because it was my my self-paced
course previously was 50 bucks or even
less it was like 25.
at the time that it was an outrageous
price yeah um it was a really it was
kind of just this bold leap to say if
i'm gonna get on calls with you over the
course of a month if i'm gonna coach you
interact with you consult with you if
i'm gonna be your personal second brand
expert yeah you know what it really was
i charged not as an online course
creator i charged as a consultant
it was as if i was your personal
consultant which with that framing 500
is cheap dude that's what it is it's
yeah it's like a reframe right it's like
500 for an online course so [ __ ] that's
really expensive but hundred dollars for
like yeah yeah basically corporate
training is like that's way too cheap
it's so cheap it's so bad it's that
cheap and we increased the price so
every cohort i would release a whole
bunch of improvements yep increase the
price by a hundred dollars so i went 600
700 800 900 there was always a reason
that it got more expensive which was
like the new features yeah uh until we
reached fifteen hundred dollars for the
lowest tier oh and then we started uh
releasing new tiers a second tier third
tier uh we stopped at 1500 because i
want it to be accessible which is funny
because like
1500
you know with one framing is not
accessible at all but we could also just
continue to raise the price but i kind
of want it to be something that
is on par with like a weekend vacation
yeah or going to a conference or
investing in a personal coach or
consultant like fifteen hundred dollars
is it's a serious amount of money but
it's there are other things in life that
we invest fifteen hundred dollars in
yeah i think it's an interesting price
point because to
some people watching and listening to
this they'll be like 1500 like how can
you possibly charge that much for
something that's completely freaking
absurd cannot believe it you're a snake
or salesman for another segment of
people watching this is like 1500 that's
like 10 times cheaper than the corporate
training i spent like 15 grand on last
week yeah and it's just like completely
different approaches to money yeah and
one thing that quite a lot of my
consulting friends have said is that
working in consulting
makes you realize how broken the world
of money actually is
because like the amount that
corporations have to spend is so
astronomically different you cannot even
fathom the scale of it compared to the
day-to-day that we spend being like that
3.50 coffee at starbucks was a little
bit expensive yeah
2.70 seems a bit more a bit more
reasonable yeah and in a way unless
you've
you know i i often struggle to
kind of explain stuff to my mom in this
sense where she's like wait you're
spending how much on this course or how
much on this office or how much of these
team members like why can't you do
everything yourself like you're doing it
yourself i'm like
for someone who doesn't have experience
in in business yeah thinking about five
six
five six figure expenses it's like
bloody hell that's like 10 years worth
of salary yeah um but it's just like a
different
yeah it's a completely different mindset
because it's tax deductible yeah
that i mean i'm in california some of
the highest taxes in the us you're in
europe
it's just a completely different mindset
because you are paying with that pre-tax
so you actually want to spend money it
is to your benefit to find as many ways
as you can spend money as possible
because then your your tax bill is the
government is in a way paying you to
spend money yeah they're giving you like
a refund on your taxes because you've
made these investments in your business
yeah and i guess there's there's gonna
be some people that think oh tax
avoidance bad but other segments like
well i mean this is how economics works
we want people to spend money yeah
providing a tax incentive for a business
to spend copious amounts of money on
individuals doing corporate training or
small businesses or big businesses it's
like that's literally how the world
works yeah like businesses spending
money and like money
essentially you know people
hate on the idea of trickle-down
economics yeah because i think it's sort
of that that phrase
then sort of gets used and applied to
the wrong things yeah and it really is
like a business where tons and tons of
money
spends that money on sort of the smaller
vendors and they spend money on the
smaller vendors and the smaller
suppliers and you end up with this
effect where like the whole economy
moves that sort of that sort of thing
yeah that's how it works i mean yeah
we do everything obviously by the book
you have to it's just not worth it you
do everything by the book but the
government is shaping your behavior
they're saying spend money here don't
spend it there we're just we're just
following the incentives and spending
money accordingly yeah like the
government says like you can't tax
deductible if i clothing for example
here but you can training and so
i'm not going to buy a fancy suit for me
to wear in video videos because that's
not legit yeah but like buying a course
it's like hell yes yeah yeah and then in
a way that incentive encourages
investment in education and training yes
in a way that it doesn't encourage
investment in clothing or in alcohol or
in petroleum or whatever things are not
tax-deductible that's how it works let's
talk about some of the concepts in the
book you mentioned something in earlier
in our conversation the idea of just in
time can you expand on that what what
does just in time mean for productivity
yeah so this goes back to manufacturing
this is i mean
just in time manufacturing completely
changed the entire world we to an extent
that we don't realize
not a lot of people know this history
but toyota uh motor company the you know
the maker of cars they introduced this
way of building cars which was instead
of stockpiling all the resources you
need you know all the the parts and the
rubber and all the different things you
know i don't know on the factory floor
they would have this network of
suppliers where they would decide what
car they're going to produce and then
just in time just days or even hours
before they would just pull they would
bring all the parts into the factory
produce it right then and ship it off
which sounds like this weird esoteric
like why does that matter it matters
tremendously by
using things just in time using
resources just in time you not only
improve speed which is nice you improve
efficiency which is great but an
unexpected thing with that is you
improve quality okay quality gets
radically higher why
it's it's kind of hard to explain it's
interesting it's basically
think about
let's take auto manufacturing if you
have a bunch of i don't know
tires right that you stockpiled a
thousand or ten thousand tires and then
you start putting them onto the
production line you find an error you
find a mistake a defect what do you do
if you've stockpiled a thousand or ten
thousand tires you just keep quiet and
you just let them all go through because
what are you gonna do you can't return
them that that one defect has been
replicated a thousand or ten thousand
times
uh and so by keeping another way of
saying this is keeping inventories low
you don't want a lot of work in process
work in process is anything that is like
in in operation in process that is
ongoing currently
uh and then applying this to knowledge
work it's interesting we also want to
keep working process low okay
when you're doing too many things at
once i mean this is just basic time
management when you have 25 projects at
once quality is going to suffer
efficiency is going to suffer time is
going to be wasted yeah so you want to
work on few things at once
yeah because i guess working on 10
things at once
rather than in a way one thing at a time
there's there's not a linear
relationship between i have 10 projects
therefore it takes
you know i can do 10 things with the
tenth of the time in the same amount i
like it there's this some efficiency
that you lose out on
by having so many bits in progress yes
similarly i think just doing things one
at a time is also for me not the sweet
spot because sometimes my energy is like
oh i actually want to work on this thing
or i can be less of a bottle and i can
think x if i focus on thing y yeah or
was to that effect yeah um so how does
that like just this idea of just in time
versus just in case how does how does
that relate to i guess personal
productivity for us in our kind of work
and personal lives
yeah so i would say just in cases how we
were kind of educated which is you do
everything
way in advance you do it as perfectly as
possible as as soon as possible
uh which is okay if you know what's
gonna happen right if you're taking a
class in school you know i need to study
each lesson each unit each paper each
reading assignment is important simply
because the professor said you know
study this
but then you leave school and it's it's
a radically higher level of uncertainty
you don't know right if you spend six
six months researching a topic
that topic may never come in handy you
may never need that skill you may never
need that knowledge
so you have to be much more dynamic and
fast moving and basically you can think
of it like just in time learning learn
something acquire knowledge right when
you need it use it fast
like we've been talking about get the
results get the feedback learn make
another iteration do it again rather
than stockpiling and growing this huge
reserve of you know material before you
even start by the way quick break from
the podcast to mention my completely
free five day email crash course for
creatorpreneurs now a creatorpreneur is
basically this portmanteau i think the
word is it's a mashup of creator and
entrepreneur it's basically a creator
who wants to scale up their creative
side hustle and turn it into more of a
business and in this completely free
five-day email crash course every day i
send you an email where i go over some
of the lessons that i've learned over
the last five years of building up this
creator printer business from the ground
up to the point that it's doing probably
something like five million dollars in
revenue every year within that you'll
also get a completely free set of links
to resources from other successful
creatorpreneurs that you can use
yourself again it's completely free so
if you want to sign up to the five-day
email crash course then you can stick
your email at the link in the video
description or in the show notes anyway
let's get back to the episode so the
book is titled building a second brain a
proven method to organize your digital
life and unlock your creative potential
um
this is a thing that we probably should
have addressed earlier but like what the
hell is a second brain and why is it
why does it help you organize your
digital life and unlock your creative
potential
yeah yeah it's a great question uh a
second brain think of it
think of things you already do so you
might have a journal
or a diary
imagine if everything you wrote in that
journal or diary was saved forever was
searchable that you could actually
derive insights from it you could go ask
it a question what have i thought about
money in the past what have i thought
about personal growth how have my dates
been in the past what did i learn you
could actually mine the insights from
that that's a journal or diary now
imagine
notes you took from books or articles
now imagine even practical things like
grocery lists
packing lists travel itineraries okay
now add bookmarks from that you save
from the web now add any kind of
document that you've created from the
past
all these things are things we largely
already do to some capacity but now
imagine getting all of that material
which like we said is just data
all of that stuff is just information
and you you save it you centralize it
all in one single central place where
you know will be preserved forever you
know you can always search for things
you know you can once it's saved in the
same place start to link things together
start to tag it start to organize it
what would be the value what would be
the
you know what would be the value of the
the aggregated sum of all that material
that's your second brain okay so a cynic
would say that well what is the value of
that why do i care if my like surely
isn't it a bad thing if my private
journal is in one place for some evil
corporation to access forever
like why do i need to care about my
shopping lists yeah books i've read i've
read a few fiction i've written twilight
i wrote 50 shades of grey in addition to
getting things done why does it matter
if it's all in one place
yeah i would say a few things if you
make anything
and i'd say more of us are makers or
creators than you would think right if
you're writing long emails if you're
writing reports memos analyses project
plans like most knowledge workers have
some virtually all knowledge workers
have some kind of output
you can't just sit down and make
something from scratch or if you do it
won't be very good you won't have a lot
of kind of interesting ideas to add to
it you need as a creative person some
repository some store of
ideas and insights to draw from or else
you're going to be doing that classic
thing that we want to avoid which is
looking at the blank page or looking at
the blank screen right and trying to
come up with an idea which is one of the
worst experiences i would say even
broader than making things think about
decisions
a decision is something that you in a
sense create right you take into account
all this information all these inputs
what your team thinks what your
colleagues think how the economy is
doing what people in your industry say
you are incorporating all of those
inputs into a decision
i would say that is something that you
need to draw on existing material uh any
kind of outcome right like it's it's
difficult to to go out into the world
sort of naked
in idea terms and make things happen
without any research without any
creative raw material without any
planning yeah it's it's just hard to do
okay
yes so the way that i kind of you know
when people ask me oh what's the deal
with the second brain thing i'm like
it's basically a you know a
digital note-taking system that you can
put anything into and that you can then
use for the things that you actually
care about yeah so i think this is very
easy to give an example to if you're for
example a writer you know there's this
idea of a commonplace book which is a
thing from from back in the day where
anytime you read a book or you have an
insight you have an idea you write it
down in this one book and now if you
have multiple of these books that you've
collected through 10 years of your life
and you come to writing a book you're
like cool i now have all of these
insights i've already gathered i've
already got the raw materials it's
almost like taking notes in class yeah
you if you're then writing an essay
you're mining the notes you've taken in
class doing a little bit of googling but
mostly doing it from stuff we've read in
class wider reading other insights maybe
a little note that sparked when you were
in a lecture and then you're assembling
your essay based on those raw materials
yeah rather than assembling your essay
from the black page or attempting to
assemble your essay via a google search
where you're just going to be uh
derailed by
seo content marketers who are writing
the most boring ass listicles to help
drive content for their things exactly
so in a way you're creating your own
google yeah your own sort of external
brain your second brain that you can
then search for relevant things yeah and
i guess that's that's easy enough to
think about like let's say if you're a
student and you're writing essays easy
enough if you're like a youtuber you're
like cool i get to mind this for content
ideas
what about like
not that not obvious things like that
well what other use cases are there for
a second brain outside the scope of i'm
a quote content creator student yeah you
know there's all these little mundane
things just from people's everyday lives
like
i'll give one very simple example i'm
driving by the hardware store
as a parent
it's like i have to make use of every
single minute if i'm driving by the
hardware store i want to take advantage
of that opportunity opportunistically no
is there anything that i could just pop
in pull in right here pick it up from
the hardware store which is across town
right
rather than trying to
from my home set aside all this time to
go to the hardware store yeah so how so
here's the question how can i within
seconds
look at some
resource someplace and know all the
things that i might want to pick up at
the hardware store
and i did that i actually have this as a
case as a like a micro case study in the
book i i went into my notes went into
the project folder for the studio that
we were building went into one note that
had things to pick up at the hardware
store right which i could have also done
a search for
and then right there in the note i kind
of reorganize it put some things at the
top put some things in a section that
says don't worry about it for now and
that way it's like i can take advantage
of a spontaneous opportunity in my day
which is driving by this hardware store
to also pick up those items which i
would never be able to remember right
and it would also be hard to sit there
in the parking lot and try to like make
a new list and try to remember all the
things that we were talking about two
weeks ago that i have to pick up
okay so it's like your second brain is
is offloading functionality from your
own brain to be forced to remember
things like three weeks from now when i
happen to be swinging by the supermarket
what are the things that i need to grab
yeah and so it's not just like notes
that you're taking from lectures as it
were or videos that you watch books that
you read it's also to-do lists for
projects that you're working on
let's say you're remodeling your studio
let's say you're i don't know getting
something installed in your kitchen
let's say you're trying to make your
bedroom look a little bit nicer yeah
those are all i guess projects yes in
our life yes and unless you're used to
thinking like a productivity nerd you
might not think of them as projects like
yes you know install bookshelf in
bedroom or sort out cable management on
desk setup like i need for that well i
need some cable ties i need one of those
like plastic boxes to put into i need
some kind of
cleaning implement for my keyboard
because my keyboard's a freaking mess um
i'm not going to bother getting those
things right now so let's just chuck
them in a to-do list such that next time
i happen to swing by the hardware store
i can just pick up those things and it
becomes a sort of seamless part of my
life is that kind of the idea exactly
yeah i think people sometimes they think
oh second brain this is this advanced
futuristic technology it's going to be
this like you know exoskeleton that's
going to give me new powers and new
capabilities
sure maybe eventually but instead think
about instead of the top of your skill
hierarchy the bottom
what is the stuff that you're trying to
memorize what is the stuff that you're
trying to keep in mind
right you know these little things are
you trying to keep in mind you know your
the homework assignments your kid has to
complete this week that you're helping
them with are you trying to keep in mind
um you know places you want to visit
next time you're in this country are you
trying to keep in mind the ideas from
the meeting with your boss last week are
you trying to keep in mind ideas that
have come up in a marketing meeting you
probably don't even realize it right
because we were never taught oh that
thing you're trying to keep in mind
don't keep that in mind in fact we're
usually taught keep this in mind
remember this like
you can even notice the things people
say in little these little
conversational moments they're like oh
can you can you
remind me of this or keep this in mind
or bring this up next time i'm always
like no
i can't i'm a fickle fragile human being
i have to write it down
so what happens if is if you replace the
instead of adding new levels of thinking
replace the bottom levels which then
frees up your time freeze up your
attention frees up your energy which you
can then dedicate to those higher levels
yeah yeah the way i think of it is like
um i think uh it's like
my brain is a dumbass and i don't trust
my brain to remember anything at all and
so if it's important i need to write it
down somewhere yeah and then i need to
remember where i've written it down yeah
and so the more second nature that
becomes and the more i know that all of
my things go in this folder yeah all my
things go in this app all my things go
in this particular notebook yeah the
more likely i am to remember the things
that actually matter to me exactly and
i've i started applying this in the in
the realm of people as well so i have
like a people folder in my apple notes
where um anytime i have a conversation
with someone and if i remember to do it
i'll just quickly be like oh
had a chat with danny on the 16th of
april 2022 we talked about x he's
thinking of moving to america he'll be
in america for a month coming back on
the 14th of may
cool that's fine sounds a bit null but
next time i speak to danny which might
be two months later i look at that note
like oh oh yeah he was in america for a
week for a month how was your trip to
america danny and that's like oh you
remembered uh and it's like we're
totally cool with writing down people's
birthdays yeah as like oh you know i'm
not gonna remember someone's birthday
but i know it's important that i
remember their birthday so i can send
them something yeah therefore i'm going
to write it down yeah
but there are also so many things about
like you know people that we know
that we want to remember yeah we just
don't trust our brain too yeah like i
don't know how old your kid is i don't
know how old francesco's kid is i know
that you guys have kids and maybe sort
of have another kid on the way i i have
dozens of friends around the process of
getting married in the
various stages of pregnancy it's like
how do you keep track of all that it's
important for those individual
relationships yeah but no one would be
like you know if for example you had a
little address book and you kind of
wrote down details yeah oh there's
something cute about it yeah you put it
in an app suddenly it's like oh my god
you're being too systematic with your
relationships what is wrong with you
you're a robot yeah it's so funny i have
a christmas notebook
christmas presents notebook every time i
come across
an item that i think could make a good
gift i just take a clip take a link take
a note and put it in there
and then at the end of the year i just
do a matching i just get a list of
everyone i need presents for open up
that notebook it's it's things i haven't
even looked at you know all year long
and then i just go okay this one for
this person this one for this person as
a result everyone thinks i'm like this
incredibly thoughtful gift giver i'm the
worst gift giver i can't remember
anything i can't remember anniversaries
birthdays nothing but using i've
essentially offloaded the part of my
brain that would be constantly thinking
or stressing out at the end of the year
oh shoot how do i buy all these gifts
and i'm just giving that job to my
second brain love it so what are the so
we've got these um kind of principles in
here um we have a whole longer video on
your channel where people can watch and
we'll link that in the video description
where you and i kind of break down in
detail with screen shares with practical
and
practical thingies and i've got a whole
other video on my main channel where i
kind of literally break down the 10 top
principles but i wonder if you can do a
quick whistle stop tour through
the principles of the second brain and
tell people where they might be able to
find out more if they're interested
yeah so basically the book is really
built around four
four pillars which are the stages of the
creative process i think the creative
process is the most important part of
people's productivity these days how do
you take inputs
and process them in some creative way
and turn them into outputs like we've
talked about and what i really sought to
do is say everyone has special things
everyone has exceptions everyone has
some unique things but what is
what is the part of the creative process
that is timeless like we can go back to
the ancient greeks we can go back to
roman times we can go back to the
renaissance the enlightenment what are
they doing that we're still doing
because if i can find some things
that's likely that we're going to keep
doing those in the future they're
timeless right
and i boil that down it's it's amazing
how long this took uh into four steps
capture organize distill and express
which underlies really
all kinds of work things have to be
captured they have to be recorded in
some way shape or form they have to be
organized in some way categorized
classified grouped they have to be
distilled you have to decide what is the
takeaway what is the main point what is
the main message
and then i think the purpose of
knowledge is to be shared is to be
expressed and so the last uh stage and
the the letters for that are c-o-d-e for
code
is express how do you
share it how do you collaborate with it
how do you apply it how do you put it
into your own words how do you put it
into some form that has a positive
impact on you your family your career or
your business
nice
that's a good summary yeah um okay so
let's just kind of break these down so
capture meaning how do i take insights
and like highlights and like notes and
shopping lists and anything from any
aspect of my life and just write it down
somewhere yes organize now that i've
written it down somewhere where does it
go yes does it get filed away in my
folder for chemistry 1a or does it get
filed away in my
bedroom remodel or does it get filed
away in my kids doctor's appointments
folder yeah that kind of thing
distill is then i guess the next step of
like for the things that i'm that are
related to my kind of creative output
whether it's a presentation for my work
because i work as a management
consultant whether it's a poster for a
scientific conference i'm working on or
a paper for this
journal submission because i'm a doctor
or a scientist whether it's a youtube
video because i'm a youtuber whether
it's a blog post because i'm a writer or
a podcast episode because i'm a podcast
like whatever the thing is yeah how do
you take the stuff
from the bits that you've saved and
figure out what are the bits that
actually matter because you end up
saving loads of stuff and then only some
of it matters yes and then the express
is the sort of the publishing basis yes
exactly okay that was a brilliant
summary thank you exactly rephrasing
what you said just like a little bit
worse um
again i i can see how this would very
much apply
in the realm of the
self-help content creator because that's
like my jam
what other kind of
case studies or use cases have you seen
of the sort of the code concept this
second brain idea
oh gosh so many i mean
people really really come from all walks
of life i've seen musicians
you know there's actually a term hook
books
a hook the hook of a song is so
important
that they will just write down either
like individual words turns of phrase
little sentences uh scenes from everyday
life you know i saw someone in red pants
get into a red cab or some just like
little snapshot
so that when they go to write the song
right imagine oh come up with a hook
what's a good hook oh my gosh like think
of something really smart and brilliant
and original ah it's like too much
stress instead they just open up the
hook book and they they might even piece
together a few of them or find some
evocative little snippet and often build
a whole song around the hook yeah yeah
i've got a friend who's a music producer
who was talking about this he was like
you know
a hook like i'm in love with the shape
of you yeah it's just like the thing
we're like okay we've got it yeah the
song is successful because the hook is
really good yes and then everything else
works around the song and they spend
hours and hours and hours and hours in
the studio being like what the hell is
the hook yes and so i guess similar to
like marketers who have a swipe file or
like artists who have like a i don't
know a mood board or an interior
designer who keeps like saving things on
pinterest for inspiration as you go
along i have like a folder on my
instagram of like menswear fashion
inspiration yes so that when when i'm in
a shop i can be like hmm oh that's a
cool thing let's go into i don't know
uniqlo or something and yeah that
particular jacket yeah i guess it's that
kind of idea of capturing yes
and what's interesting about that is
everything has a hook
this is something amazing i've i've
discovered you know i was talking to my
my other brother who's a ballroom dancer
would seem to be very different from you
know creating self-help content but he
he showed me that when you're ballroom
dancing there's this thing you do with
your hands it's like a flourish you know
you you like do a turn and then you kind
of reach out to the side and go and go
like that with your hand yeah and he
told me that's the hook the way you can
just look at someone's hand and tell how
good of a dancer they are because that
is what attracts the attention that is
what completes the movement that is what
that is this like singular moment that
defines the quality of the dance
look at a building
if you just look at a building your eye
goes to certain it's it's not that
you're looking at the whole building
equally it goes to the crowning on the
window it goes to some little detail it
goes to some
some material so in anything there is
some there is one part of it that is
more important and that's like the hook
and that's that's a great example of
it's hard to come up with those things
on demand it's hard to come up with a
brilliant hook but it is worth just in
your everyday this is what i'm saying in
your everyday life don't make any extra
special effort just live your your
normal life but when you come across
those moments from a museum you go to
perusing a bookstore something you hear
on tv something you hear on the radio
something that happens to you something
you feel just write that down and you
will be amazed when you after
a week a month open that thing up and
you will realize you have a way more
interesting life than you realize
i love it can we talk about this idea of
constraints
um
you've said that word a couple of times
and even before recording you mentioned
the idea of constraints like
what what does how does that relate to
this kind of stuff that we're talking
about yeah let's see this is a super
interesting subject i think okay the way
i would talk about this is
what makes knowledge work so difficult
one of the things is that there's no
constraints there's no limits
you know how much data can you download
essentially infinite you know how many
like how many sources of information do
you have essentially infinite yep then
on the output side how many different
ways can you use an idea infinite how
many different kinds of projects can you
pursue how many different kinds of goals
could you have yeah it's not that you
can do it all yeah but the optionality
is so great it's overwhelming as humans
we were not designed to have
such a vast optionality right be able to
date anyone in your city be able to eat
any kind of cuisine from the entire
world be able to you know read any story
from any corner of the world it's it's
actually maddening to have that many
options
and so i think a lot of what my book is
doing is
creating constraints around knowledge
work it is actually
reining in that optionality the vast
amount of options i mean even code right
code is just saying okay right now just
capture it's like a rule there's a limit
to it just write the thing down don't
worry about anything else then at a
separate time just organize right like
you're creating these very discreet
stages instead of trying to do all the
activities all the time there are
designated times to do different kinds
of thinking
yeah there's such a common thing with
writing as well it's like research isn't
a step and then the first draft is a
step and then writing is a step and then
editing is a different step and ideally
these things happen at different times
because you need to be in a different
kind of brain space yeah do the thing
yeah and if you try and do all the
things at once and nothing ever gets
done yes yeah i think this was one of
the key things that i learned from you
kind of from from your course and your
blog that i then applied to the youtube
channel of like actually you know i idea
generation is a thing that happens over
time
in a in in one sitting then coming up
with like title and thumbnail is a very
different skill to coming up with the
structure of the video which is a very
different skill to think now i'm filming
the video which is very way different
skill to sing down editing the video and
back in the day when i was trying to do
these things all at once or one after
the other for one project at a time it
would feel quite overwhelming yeah
whereas when i think of it like oh i've
got three minutes in between patients at
work cool let's come up with a few
bullet points for my next video done or
let me just generate five more video
ideas or whatever that thing might be
for other people um
that's how i guess you can quote be more
productive i
use time more intentionally yeah whereas
otherwise what i would have ended up
doing is scrolling on instagram yeah and
i'm so glad i spent those like three to
five minute blocks here and there um
doing stuff that contributed to the
thing i genuinely cared about i eat
making youtube videos and growing the
channel and trying to build this
business yeah rather than aimlessly
scrolling through instagram yeah and i
have no idea what i scrolled through and
has added zero value to my life overall
i think that's that's such a good
observation
yeah you're you're making use you're
able to make use of smaller amounts of
time because
you're not trying to
reinvent
the wheel here you know you have three
to five minutes what can you do in three
to five minutes
i always just think can i make one note
a note can be one sentence one bullet
point
that is likely to have future value i
can i can do that in 30 seconds right it
could be one quote one idea sometimes i
even do like just the title of the note
can i think of without even i can't even
think of the content i'm too tired i
don't have time can i even think of the
title of a no that when my future self
sees that will spark ideas to then fill
in the content the body of the note
it's really amazing once you scale it
down that's that low
and also have a place to save it right
if you don't have confidence that when
you hit save that note is going to be
saved somewhere that you can then
revisit it then you're it's not going to
be worth the trouble yeah i think i
think that's that's a big part of it
yeah and i guess this reminds me of how
like it's pretty common advice for
basically any kind of creative at least
to always have
a notebook with you in your pocket
preferably one of ours in our
essentially line that says this is going
to be fun um because so that when you
come across something interesting or
something inspirational you have a thing
that you can just a thing in your pocket
to write it down and given that most of
us don't carry notebooks anymore but we
always have our phones with us yeah i
guess the second brain is basically a
sort of pocket notebook but on steroids
so that anything can go into it and you
know it's going to be coming it's going
to come in handy at some point further
down the line exactly yeah we have our
phone more than any
any notebook you could ever have even if
you don't have your phone if you have a
tablet if you can
find a computer log into your account
there or your apple watch or you know
soon there's going to be smart glasses
and airpods and all these things
it's it's just exactly what you said
it's that creative notebook that is so
obviously useful i mean just look at it
you use it all the time except in
digital form that's what we're doing
nice yeah yeah people often ask me um
like how did you manage to do all the
things how did you do the youtube
channel and stuff while working
full-time i have a full-time job like
life is so hard i can't i can't make
time for my thing i think it's always
like
i mean a find a way to make it fun and
like make it make the process of the
thing doing the thing itself so
energizing that it makes you want to do
it in the evenings or the weekends or
whatever but also like no one genuinely
works for like eight or 10 12 hours a
day there's always moments of downtime
yeah even in the most demanding jobs
even in even working medicine where this
like super super busy day there's always
going to be a little bit of down time
for lunch a little bit of time on the
toilet where if i wanted to i could
spend those five minutes just like doing
something and contributing towards this
project that i really care about yeah um
i think the the crucial thing there is
like figure out what what are the things
you care about what are the projects
what are the goals you're working on and
then find ways to quit be more
productive and you use your time more
intentionally and effectively to get
those things because that's hopefully
what is contributing to your meaningful
and fulfilling life
couldn't have said it better myself i
love it so this is a great place to end
the conversation tiago thank you so much
for coming down we will link to all of
the things the book uh your blog your
youtube channel um more recently your
podcast which basically is like short
episodes that summarize all the concepts
of building second brain i will link to
the course as well if anyone wants to
take it i took the course three years
ago now genuinely changed my life i was
a mentor on the course as well and we
will also link over here somewhere to
the youtube video that you and i are
doing and i will also have a summary of
this book available on my main channel
uh
by the time you're watching this so
thank you so much for listening everyone
amazing thank you for coming on tiago
thank you so much all right so that's it
for this week's episode of deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
gonna be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye